there are so many amazing planets and
moons scattered all through the Star
Wars universe and as sad as it may be
most of these will never feature in the
movies and even those that do share
limited screen time so we never really
get to explore them so today we begin
with a personal favorite of mine nor
shudder also known as the smugglers moon
although Naruto does appear in Cannon
here and there it's never really
expanded on and it wasn't until i first
played Star Wars The Old Republic that I
really began to appreciate the moon nor
shadow is located in hut space and
orbits the planet hotter
homeworld of the Hutt cartel it is the
largest of the five moons that orbit the
planet and as its nickname may suggest
the smugglers moon was a hotbed of
criminal activity regulated by the Hutts
the criminal organizations operate side
by side with legitimate enterprises to
ensure there was no unnecessary
attention due to its large population
the moon was a great place for fugitives
to hide as it was very unlikely
authorities would venture anywhere near
Narsha da nasha da was a haven for those
who wish to partake in activities that
may have been frowned upon by the
Republic or the Sith Empire filled with
towering skyscrapers casinos and illegal
spice houses the moon was home to every
type of underground business that one
could imagine nor should our structure
could be compared to that of Coruscant
as the moon resembled one large city but
up close nor shaddoll was a filthy
polluted and dangerous place with a
notoriously high murder and
disappearance rate which should come to
no surprise as the planet was run by
gangsters pirates and slavers despite
the clear rule of underground syndicates
Republican imperial representatives
competed for influence and business with
local powers and authorities the
legitimate businesses of Nar Shaddaa
were located on its highest levels many
of these served as fronts for illegal
activities
beneath the were presented and polished
exterior of its highest levels was the
underbelly of Nar Shaddaa
the underbelly was home to many of the
crime bosses who were vying for power
here corruption was at an all-time high
and the numerous underworld conflicts
between the Hutt cartel and the exchange
syndicate were not policed during the
Great War nor should our chose to remain
neutral dealing to both the Republic and
the Sith Empire to maximize their profit
neither side was happy with the agreed
terms but they realized they could not
risk a disagreement with the cartels
this would give their opposition a huge
advantage before the invasion of Naboo
Darth Maul traveled to a bar in our
shadow where he was looking for
information on the cartels auction of a
Jedi that he wished to test these
abilities against being mistaken for a
Jedi a brew Lear upped it between Maul
and those in the bar he was saved by a
group of bounty hunters led by CAD Bane
he later enlisted the services of CAD
Bane to track down the Jedi after being
sold the cartel ship was rigged and
crash-landed on the moon of Dre's goal
surviving the crash more freed her and
together they defeated the hunters that
were after them the two eventually
dueled and it was the Sith apprentice
that emerged victorious in the Marvel
comic Skywalker strikes part 4 we see
Luke Skywalker traveled to nosh Adar
looking for a way to enter the Jedi
Temple on Coruscant
unfortunately Luke was extremely vocal
and gave her too much information
leading to his capture by Krakus the
Hutt who forced him into gladiatorial
combat he was eventually able to escape
when a dispute between a group of storm
troopers and the Hutt cartel turned
violent
Narsha da served as a symbol of
corruption pleasure and excess a safe
haven for smugglers bounty hunters and
the galaxy's most unsavory individuals
the smugglers moon provided the galaxy
of one of the largest black markets and
served as a reminder that not all
planets and moons would submit to the
control of the Republic in the Sith
Empire hopefully you guys enjoyed
today's video and learned a little bit
about the smugglers moon let me know in
the comments below if there's any
planets you'd like to see me cover in
the future as always I've been your host
mythology in fiction explained